now a poll in the sunday times today
about the future of the uk will have
unnerved unionists across the country
this morning particularly in northern
ireland
it found a majority of people in
northern ireland would like to see a
border pole or a referendum on
unification with ireland
within five years 44
didn't think this should happen within
five years 48
meanwhile think it's likely that
northern ireland will vote for
unification with ireland
within a decade and that's more than the
44
who think that's unlikely well we're
joined by the perfect person to discuss
this northern ireland's first minister
and dup leader
arlene foster good to see you this
morning
um look in terms of in terms of this
poll
this must have you worried surely
well i think first of all we have to
remember that this is an internet pool
so that always comes
out with a health warning but whatever
about that
i think it is very disappointing to see
that some nationalist parties across the
united kingdom
during a time of national crisis when
i'm focusing every
uh working r on trying to save lives
are actually trying to take this
opportunity to talk about constitutional
politics i mean we all know
how divisive a border pole would be and
for us in northern ireland what we have
to do at the moment is all come together
to fight
against covet and not be distracted by
what would be
absolutely reckless at this time we are
going to uh
talk about kovid in just a moment but in
terms of it being
divisive i mean is it really i mean the
long-standing
rule has always been hasn't it that if a
majority of people wanted a referendum
then a referendum would
happen are you dead against that now
no it's not that i'm dead against it i
can argue for united kingdom
every day of the week because of course
the arguments are rational they're
logical and they will win through and i
mean nobody's suggesting
and not even this poll is suggesting
that
we would lose in that if there was a
border pole
but of course it would be incredibly
divisive and i think most people in
northern ireland
want us to deal with what's in front of
us at present and of course what's in
front of us
is dealing with a pandemic and actually
settling down in northern ireland we
only came back into the evolution
after three years out of devolution in
january of last year
therefore and then we came into the
pandemic in march therefore we need to
get on with dealing with all of the
things that matter to everybody in their
everyday lives
and that's what i'm focused on and
that's what everybody should be focused
on
your deputy first minister michelle
o'neill from champaign of course
has tweeted to say there is an
unstoppable conversation underway
on our constitutional future we can
overcome the barriers of partition and
build a new island well
yeah we know that's that's the ultimate
goal that that shin fein
would want but is she right to say that
this conversation has started and
whatever else is going on in the world
and these huge priorities that you talk
about
this conversation still needs to be held
well i mean the conversation's been
going on for 100 years
actually we're celebrating our centenary
now this year
and when people have the conversation
and nobody fears having the conversation
because of course we've seen throughout
the pandemic just the strength of the
united kingdom
the fact that we have uh three billion
pounds from the united kingdom
government to fight coronavirus we've
had the furlough scheme
we've had the rule out of the
vaccination in a way of course you don't
see
in the republic of ireland our national
health service has proven to be so
important to all of our citizens and
then of course because we're under such
incredible pressure at the moment
in our national health service our
military can provide that backup that
we've received just last week and when i
spoke to
the defense minister uh just on friday
ben wallace he was very clear that if we
needed any further assistance we could
have that assistance so there
in a very tangible way is actually the
strength of the united kingdom
um in terms of that strength though is
isn't that or hasn't that been damaged
from your perspective
by the whole brexit arrangements as they
currently stand i mean
you are sort of economically as much in
the eu as you are in the uk aren't you
no absolutely not our biggest market by
far
is great britain it will continue to be
great britain both in terms of who we
send our services and goods to and where
we receive our services and goods from
there are of course difficulties with
the protocol difficulties which we
warned about when it was
envisaged and put through in parliament
however we're working with
our government to make sure that we
overcome
those difficulties and whether it's in
relation to vat and second-hand cars or
tariff on steel or indeed parcels coming
into northern ireland we have to work
through those difficulties and make sure
that we find a solution
do you wish i mean i know politicians
never want to
sort of have a great deal of hindsight
in a way understandably so but do you
wish you'd back teresa may's deal
no absolutely not because of course
theresa may's deal would have left us in
the eu
customs union and indeed the single
market forever if you remember
the attorney general jeffrey cox at that
time said that we would
not have any escape rip from any uh eu
customs union or indeed the single
market so
i think people are having a little bit
of revisionism
around theresa may's deal but they
should revisit it and see what it meant
for us in northern ireland and i think
they will come to the conclusion that it
certainly was not a better deal
as you say your priority at the moment
is the covert situation
and you know obviously quite quite
rightly so um
you've said that restrictions are going
to be extended until
march march the 5th i think i mean your
health minister says it's unrealistic
for those restrictions to necessarily
end at that point do you agree with him
well i think what we'll do is on the
18th of february we'll review where we
are in terms of the pandemic what the
positive case numbers are at that point
in time how is
our hospitals coping with the pandemic
what are the number
of deaths at that time and we will
review all of that because i've often
said
none of this is inevitable what we need
to have is people working with us so
that we can
overcome this dreadful virus and now
that we have the vaccine program running
out so effectively
in northern ireland that gives a lot of
hope for people in the future
so we just need to keep working together
and make sure that we get to the end of
this journey
and make sure that we get through it so
that we can rebuild
our economy and society here in northern
ireland
it's going to be a hugely difficult few
weeks ahead though isn't it because we
know
hospitals in northern ireland are
already under tremendous strain hospital
admissions we expect to peak
some point in the next eight to ten days
the number
requiring intensive care treatment is
expected to continue
to increase for more than a fortnight
now i mean
how are you what are you doing to help
ease if you can
any of the pressure on hospitals and
icus
well it's very important that the
community realizes the pressure on our
hospitals and support
our health service workers and recognize
the pressure and sacrifice that they're
making for
the community and large and in doing so
they must keep to the restrictions and
keep to in what they have been doing i
mean
there's only a tiny minority of people
and i think this is true across the
united kingdom
who are breaking uh the restrictions so
it's important that we all stick
together
but also recognize the help that we are
getting from the military who are
sending in extra resources into our
hospital
and again as i said the ben wallace said
that if we needed
any further help in relation to that he
would be willing to do that and i think
that's really good
for us in northern ireland to know that
there that there is an extra resource
there
if we need it but in terms of planning
forward you've got to look at what's
happened in the past the head of the bma
in northern ireland says hospital staff
are exhausted and demoralized and he
said this phase will stand out as one
where we could have planned better are
you talking to people like him to see
how you can change that planning moving
forward
well look i think everybody recognizes
and i noticed the health secretary was
saying this as well at the beginning of
your program
that we are dealing with a a novel virus
therefore there's no textbook and
as to how we deal with this matter we're
learning all the time
in relation to how we combat this virus
and of course we're speaking to everyone
who has a voice in relation to these
issues
so that we can plan better but let us
hope given that we have the vaccine in
place here now
that we can move forward in a more
positive way yes there will
be new variants and we'll have to cope
with that but one of the benefits
again of being in the united kingdom is
that we're part of cog uk
which is the covet 19 genomic testing
regime
and don't forget that the uk alone tests
40 percent more than anywhere else in
the uk so we're doing 40 percent of the
genomic testing across the world
and of course because of our membership
of the united kingdom
we're part of that testing regime first
minister good to talk to you this
morning thank you